yep we're gonna get started and
hopefully you all can can see I will be
doing some coding so I apologize if you
are in the middle and can't see I will
try and move out the way so you can see
what we're doing and but thank you for
coming I'm Martin Thwaites and I'm VP of
engineering a company called mango and
it's the digital arm for Manchester
Airport group and we do a lot of high
load web systems and that we do it's not
traffic control because you know life's
too short to route those systems and but
we do do things that are fairly high
load so 10,000 requests a second we're
monitoring 125,000 price points at any
given point so there's quite a lot of
observability that we need to see in
there for us production is the only
place that we can do these things so
things like logging and metrics and what
we'll come onto with events is really
important to us so we start by asking a
couple questions and just to see what
level we're out this is meant as an
entry level tour for people who've not
ventured into login of metrics in dotnet
core before so how many people here do
centralize logging right now okay right
and that's good and you're doing the
right thing and of those people how many
people have actually looked into those
logs and looked to any data that was
longer than a month ago cool that's
that's exactly what I was hoping and now
a lot of people believe that logs there
they're quite expensive to store and
they people do tend to keep them for a
long period of time and now a lot of the
big providers they do fifteen eighteen
months worth of retention which is
completely ludicrous and so that was
very telling and if you are storing them
for that long and your providers it's
probably worth having a a look at
whether that is right I apologise those
are they're in the wrong order
we are going to do logging first and
bought bit of things what we're going to
do we're going to look at some metrics
what they
our metrics and what they use for we're
also going to look at actually building
some code inside of a brand new solution
and to actually do it and we're gonna
look at some logging so specifically we
going to look at four metrics at metrics
for logging we're gonna look at Sarah
log and then eventing and tracing
towards the end we're gonna look at a
company called honeycomb which is a
commercial solution it's the only one
the commercial solution that were
looking at and but they are a
differentiate and do things a little bit
differently and so what is logging and
it is meant to be human readable that is
one of the facets of logging it was
always built to be read by a human not
read by a computer
it wasn't read meant to be read by a
human this kind of thing that you see
here person X called the function that
that's very I've seen that all over the
place not really helpful a lot of the
time but it is what people use and there
is structure logging and stretch logging
as kind of somebody is probably going to
tell me it's like 20 years old but it's
new to me and so they end up being quite
verbose locks and which is why they're
expensive to store there's quite a few
ways you can do it and some of these you
may be familiar with obviously Sarah log
in the top left there is the one that
we're going to be looking at a couple of
ways to store it so Splunk logs iodate a
dog stack if i all log aggregation
providers that you can use and if you
are of a certain age you will remember
back to log for net and and log and my
apologies if you are still using them
and but they are a little bit outdated
in my opinion right now so what changed
in donek core and now wait wait wait
back and when you were creating a
solution you do file new projects then
you'd probably spend in the region about
six weeks deciding which logging
framework you're going to use because it
was going to be baked in throughout your
entire solution you had to make that
choice up front with dotnet core they
brought in two new interfaces which is
ilogger a log of T that's baked into the
framework now you don't have to make
these decisions from around what login
framework you can do file new projects
let's
go we've got logging in place we've got
console.log in there we can choose what
we're going to do with that logging
after the fact so already you've saved
six weeks of your project of people
arguing which is great and it is
incredibly easy to use it is dependency
injection all throughout your code base
so great you can just inject it into the
top it is library agnostic depending on
which library you are using under the
hood it will or will not support
structured login Sarah log is a log in
provider that you can plug into ilogger
it is incredibly easy plumbing to do
what you are and what you need to do a
few lines of coding you start up will
get you Sarah log that will just replace
your console logging with something that
looks basically the same bit of
colorization that kind of stuff
bought a couple more lines of code and
you've now got a centralized login and
it is that easy to add that in there and
we will go through a little bit of code
and I'll show you what we're doing now
what I'm going to do we're going to use
the elasticsearch I'm going to run this
up in some docket containers and so
hopefully and the demos will work
because this is live coding so and I
have literally just created a solution
it's got dr. compose file in there with
some elasticsearch and Cabana in flux
and Ravana and and with any luck this
will just go straight now what I'm
trying to show here is exactly how easy
is it to bring up a centralized login
cluster you can test all this locally I
am running this in the interactive mode
just to be clear always run it in
interactive mode locally because it
makes it look like you're doing lots
more work than you are doing and cool so
just to prove there is no magic at play
here
let's not update a Visual Studio code in
the middle of a presentation
so literally just create a brand-new
solution and and we're not is that sighs
okay everybody see it yeah good
Oh that's maybe a bit too big think
that's about the best we're gonna get
and so I'm assuming a lot of people have
seen this before it's a basic done that
new website now if we switch back you'll
see that you now got console logging in
there it's baked in that I've done
nothing to get that console log in it so
obviously we don't like the default
logging we want to get something as a
login framework in there so first thing
we do add a couple of references in I'm
going to use a copious amounts of
snippets here if anybody believes that
that's cheating when doing live code
there's a door over there so Sarah logs
in there and we've got a couple of
packages were brought in so the asp.net
core plug-in that's going to plug it
into the pipeline it's going to give us
some some additional data in there and
we've got the console sink and the
elasticsearch think and sorry I'm gonna
have to reformat that because that will
bug me if that didn't book anybody else
out here you're not real programmers so
right so we've now got that in there and
now what we need to do add it into our
hosts file here
and at a reference when it decides it
wants to work
that is just
and what you should see is the layout of
that has slightly changed so from a
couple lines of code you can now verify
that you've got and Sarah log in place
you can see that that is slightly
different to the login we had before I'm
not saying who deserves a round of
applause but if you and so that in
itself isn't really amazing and but what
we want to do is we want to show
centralized logging and how we can get
from nothing into some kind of
centralized login so if we add
elasticsearch in now remember I've got
my docket contain Israeli and nothing
special about them you saw the docker
compose file it is just containers it's
not special I'm sorry if anybody really
looks containers but they're not special
and so my cup now you don't access
elasticsearch directly if anybody
doesn't know you access Cabana or Cabana
depending on how posh you actually ow
right and don't need to be aware of this
this is just me showing that it is very
very simple to set up
and summers probably gonna tell me
there's a quicker way but
and they go got some logging in there
that's as easy as it is to get some
centralized logging in place in da
Nicole so what's that something like 20
minutes including talking and we've got
centralized logging that is not
complicated it is not there is no magic
so what you've also got in here is it's
automatically done structured logging
and it's automatically pulled all these
out now because we founded it in this
way what we've now got is all of these
fields that are now searchable in our
log in so we can now do any kind of
filtering we can probably do some
graphing on top of it as well but I
never advise doing graphs on top of logs
and that's what metrics and other things
are for but you can and so that is not
really impressive in my opinion but what
we can do is we can now go in and show
off some of our login
helps if you put it in the controller
problem and that action apparently
okay so pulling our logo - in front of
people is really hard it's like if
somebody at one person is watching you
it's really hard try multiplying that
and silence
her right so again we've not done
anything really special here all we've
done is injected something in there
right we've we've not done anything
special and I would have done all this
with a pre-built solution but what I'm
trying to prove here is exactly how
quickly can you add something into your
solution to get some really really
decent login okay so we've got an
information log there we've also got a
critical exception which I hope doesn't
happen later
so let's restart that and if we jump
into here here our log function now you
notice I've added some questioning
parameters in the end of that and we'll
come to why those are there in a minute
so in our login now again I'm not using
consul now I'm just going to use and use
it through here we can now search
through our locks for those so you can
see there we've got an Oslo thing in
there and if we now search for the
violation
you've now got your exception in there
we use that race again it's all
searchable now and we've not done
anything special this is the power of
what dotnet core is added cool so I
mentioned before structured login none
of that is doing actual structured login
what we've done there is we've taken
stuff that's enriched our logs we've
added stuff that's come in by this area
log asp.net package that kind of stuff
now structured logging allows you to be
a little bit better with your login so
what we're doing here is we're adding in
a pram subject and we've just taken the
query string out of it and we're going
to throw that one in there now you could
if you wanted to just concatenate that
put some commas in between and you still
get the same actual log message out and
bought where's the fun in that
so what we're doing here this specific
out sign inside of there so what's life
string interpolation but it's not with
the out sign says do something special
with it so we should wait for it so
so questioning parameters in there I've
added conference and location now if we
now look through and look for the same
thing
well you should see now is the log
message it's done some serialization for
us buying I suppose but what's really
important is its extracted those as
field as well so just by saying I want
to throw this object in there
what we've now got is some searchable
data inside an elastic search cluster
that is pure open-source there is no
costs other than hardware that kind of
stuff around building it now you've got
a hard problem of running elastic search
which we are not going into because
that's much bigger topic and but that's
it that is that is logging it's not it's
not hard anymore there's not what you
used to have with things like an elk
where you'd have your text-based logs
and you would then throw some some
parsing in there and try and extract
that information then throw that into
elastic search you've not got any of
that anymore it does it all for you
that's logging and simple as that right
so I'm going to move on there will be
time for questions at the end if anybody
has any assal and okay metrics different
to logs they are you can build metrics
from logs
I advise never to do that but you can do
it metrics are different they are about
numbers they're all numbers there are
numbers formatted in particular ways
stored in particular ways but they are
all about numbers they might have tags
to give them some description but they
are about numbers their time series
based so they are something happened
over this particular period of time they
are aggregated for those time periods
and they're optimized for that that is
their purpose now if you don't if you've
not seen any of these metrics before
probably not in the right room they're
obvious metrics that you would have
bought hits per second transactions per
day they request times that you're
sending over to your payment service
provider or your third party who's
giving you some information that's
that's what metrics are all about
however they have some good points and
bad points well and so they're very very
fast queries because they're numbers and
because they're aggregated you
can query the large amounts of data vast
amounts of data for very little resource
very very quickly they're very very
cheap to store because you can store
massive amounts of data in a small
amount of space however you lose
fidelity so you can't say for that
request on Tuesday at one minute past
six bye Joe can I can you tell me what
happened well no I can't I can tell you
how many requests were in that period I
can tell you what the average response
time was all of that kind of stuff but
you lose that fidelity to go into
individual requests that's not
particularly bad thing in a lot of
circumstances but it is a limitation of
them they're also predefined by the
visualizations that you want to do so
you've got to think up front with your
metrics how am I going to be displaying
this to my bosses my my peers so you've
got to think about it up front which is
potentially a problem because you can't
go back and add metrics unless you build
a time machine and if you can do that
you're probably in the wrong room again
so a few different technologies and so I
think most people have moved away from
open csdb and graphite I think there are
still some people using it bought most
people now stick in one of the top-two
time scale is a new one built on top of
Postgres so if you're already on
Postgres it looks really really good
I've not done anything with it but it
does look really really good so I'd
advise you if you are using Postgres
have a look at it in flux DB is probably
the market leader I think most people
are using that there is a commercial
offering and a free offering we're going
to be looking at the free offering
Prometheus however is the differentiator
so Prometheus is pulling metrics from
your system as opposed to you pushing
metrics and to it there are ways around
that but generally the way the
Prometheus works is it will call your
apple set application and say can I have
your metrics please which is why it's
very very big in the containerized in
service discovery world now none of
those well they do offer graphs but I
wouldn't use them in any way shape or
form they do offer graphs generally
people use graph and on top of that you
think that using all loader systems
together is going to be a problem it's
actually really easy to throw everything
and we'll you'll see an example of that
now what's new in donut core now if you
think back when your full frame work
done they're running on Windows you may
be familiar with these things and they
were great because you could buy
something off the shelf sign over your
firstborn to a third pie company and
they would just look at your performance
metrics and performance counters and
give you some pretty graphs that you can
put in front of your management team and
yeah we're doing stuff we're monitoring
it however when we went cross-platform
those don't exist anymore so we don't
have those so now you've got to think
about instrumenting new code yourself
which is where our metrics comes in and
so it's a little bit harder and because
you've got to start thinking about
yourself and you can't just offload it
on to a third party there are ones that
are trying to do a lot in that space and
with the advent of something called
diagnostic sauce and and the activities
and all that kind of stuff it is proving
to be a little bit easier and I can see
it going in that way but this is
something from dotnet called
to which a lot of that was in its
infancy when I started doing this so
again very easy to do things with
literally pull it in eClass define what
your counter is and then just increment
it wrap something in a timer and job
done plumbing it into your application
again really really easy a few lines of
code at the top and then tell it to use
The Awl matrix middle Wellcome to what
that is so I said before the the big
tools that you pay a fortune for and
they provide some nice pretty graphs now
if you add this little bit lip lip line
in here and you can bind that with
Griffin elapse there is a pre-built
dashboard that'll bring you some pretty
grass back now they don't do anything
you shouldn't actually use them they've
got a pie chart pie chats me nothing but
management like them so if you want to
prove that you are doing something do
that and then do the real stuff so again
we're going to go through how quick and
easy that is so I brought an influx DB
and Agra fauna as part the cluster that
we're talking about before we're going
to use the same solution
and bring it in
so again snippets never do a
presentation without the snippets and so
at metrics we're bringing it in we're
bringing in the app metrics don''t core
is what's going to give us all of these
nice fancy graphs that we don't really
need we've also got this reporting thing
now that's using the background service
functionality in and donate call to poll
and push metrics out for us and we're
using the reporter for influx TV there
are all the reporters you can use I
think you can actually write to a file
if you really want to and then ingest it
through elke if you really hate yourself
okay so we've done that
and now inside our startup we will pull
in just don't get rid of that and we'll
throw in our builder
okay one really good thing about the s
code when it crashes just restart but
you don't have to shut Visual Studio
down then go for a brew and come back
and and do it okay
cool so we've got on in there and as I
said before we're adding in the they
should really name this app dot make
management reports just like that
so
let's run that up
and get rid of that
now what I've done is when we get to the
end of this there is a pre-built
solution I'll put up on github with the
the docker compose script so you are
welcome to use it on your own
all you literally the only requirement
is done at core and docked for Windows
that's literally it so I'm gonna use
graph honor and because I've spun this
up from scratch it's gonna ask me to
reset the password that's be proving
that I have not pre-built any of this so
we're gonna add our in flux DB data
source so Gravano itself doesn't have
any data it is just a graphing solution
he doesn't store anything internally and
doesn't store the aggregates that kind
of stuff it literally just queries the
underlined data sources so we're gonna
write in flux DB and we're gonna add in
flux DB 8086 and I was agonizing over
the name of this metrics database and
all night last night obviously and
called my metrics now this is where you
can then import a management dashboard
now I know that he's called it's two one
two five because I've done this a couple
of times so but there is a website where
you can go on to and it will show you
all this now that's that's metrics we've
got some metrics in there from a very
very small amount of code that we've
just added we've now got some metrics in
there all you need to find is a way to
host in flux TV and a way to host qivana
and you've got it it's there and there's
a few graphs on there fully off the
default doesn't act the default graph on
our instance doesn't have a pie chart in
there because they obviously know the
pie charts mean nothing and bought
you've got requests per minute you've
got various different bits and bobs but
like I say for me
it doesn't really do anything for me now
what you can then do is we can start
doing our own ones that actually mean
something so inside of our log function
again we're going to have to pull in our
metrics
I love underscore notation but I can't
get this code to do it automatically
alone and so we've with Brian our
metrics we now need to add a counter so
the counter is what defines how we're
going to push this in what tags we're
gonna use how is it going to bring
everything together when it logs these
out and do the same with timers and
there's various different functions of
all of these tools that I'm talking
about I'm really going very superficial
over the top of this they do so much
more and I would advise you to go in and
have a look at what other things you can
do okay so know your own snippets okay
so we've had in in our increment action
which
some reason thinks it's something else
okay try that again what are the metrics
and there we go
because I didn't have encountering
cool so we should now have our increment
action sorry I need to format out okay
so got our in crime action what we've a
couple of things we've done here so I've
said we're going to pull an attack in
the in the query string and I'm going to
add this as tags on to the metrics so
this is allowing us to filter that
metric so you'll come to when you when
we add this to the query in graph our
know exactly what that means and why
that's that's quite useful okay
so incrementally bits and let's add a
tag off and you see Oslo and 2019 okay
so forget about that dashboard and okay
so that one that dashboard we pulled in
is pulled in a load of stuff it's
assumed that you've got metrics called
different things because it was built by
the people at metrics it is correlated
with the two because we've added our own
ones we're gonna now need to add our own
query in there add in influx DB because
that's our data source
obviously graph honor can be query
multiple data sources on the same
dashboard that you do and you can see
that we've now added our home counter
which is the one I've just added and you
can see we've got some data and if we
squeeze that in in the last five minutes
you can see some data points coming
through the stuff that we've done now I
said that we've added some tags so I can
add in here and say I want this
particular graph to be only the ones
that have been tagged with a particular
thing or you can say I want it all it's
as simple as that and you want to add in
and the song for instance
and let's filter it for just the 2019
ones you've got all the things in there
there's loads of options loads of
options on what are you doing but that's
just the counter there's timers and
there's a histogram function in there
you've really can go to town with what
you're doing but the key is here
thinking about what you want to log what
are your key metrics and how are you
going to put those in there once you've
got those lines of code in there it's
easy you can just hand it over to the
rest of the people on the team that are
doing this doing their features right
you're doing a feature great okay what
metrics are you going to add in there
it's literally a case of you going
I metrics in the controller I metrics in
any one of your service classes and away
with it okay that is metrics we are
running well ahead of time and cool so
I'll try and slow down a little bit so
and so events are a bit of an
intersection between the two they're in
my opinion quite new but it's a
different way of thinking so when you
think about logs and structured logs
structured logs are probably a lot
closer to events and traces and that
kind of stuff but the idea in the
movement around observability in general
and events is around not losing that
fidelity it's about very very high
cardinality log every single request log
every bit of data you possibly can but
don't snow it for very long now
everybody I would imagine has had some
kind of production issue an issue that
only ever happens in production that
you've got to debug now what is the best
way to debug an issue well that we've
got a debugger just attach it as anybody
has ever attempted attaching a debugger
to a production assistant did it go well
on it on a web system attaching the
debugger stopping all of the threads on
the server not really what you want to
do so what's the next best thing
well I want all
the information that happened every
little bit of it I want to be able to
drill in find out what the request
response time was what time did this
request start what time did that request
start what time what parameters were
passed into each one of the functions
down the way if you've got all of that
information so that every single request
that happened and you've got a tool that
can then bring all of that together and
show you it and allow you to navigate it
that to me is the next best thing to
being able to attach the debugger to
production if somebody can create
something where I can attach a debugger
to production and replay that I know
there is a few that do some similar
things but I've never had success with
them but and that is what events is
trying to solve it's trying to solve the
idea that things only happen in
production now I mentioned our use case
at the airport where we have 10,000
requests going through a second a lot of
the bugs that we come across only happen
at load they only happen with production
data where you have all of those Python
you've got administrators accessing the
system got users accessing the system
all at the same time so the only place
where we can replicate these issues and
debug them is in production so this is
where we had to go now the the other
point the other problem with this is a
similar problem symetric s-- which is
their deliberate you've got to work out
what you're going to store obviously the
more you store the more it costs you to
store or more specifically the lower
retention you can have and that is the
idea around this is it's increasing your
visibility within the system or how
observable the system is but they're
built for debugging but keep them for
four days I always say four days because
there's a weekend and a lot of us don't
work weekends because we're smart people
and so you come in on a Monday you want
the last four days worth of log so you
can be able to see these production
issues be able to debug them drill into
what the data was drill into what was
happening at the time that kind of stuff
bought though the question the star was
exactly around this people store their
logs their structured logs for months
and months and months because that's
what you used to do but nobody ever
looks at them so
restoring them it's a GDP um nightmare
storing logs for that long so low
retention keep them just for the amount
of time that you need it therefore you
get a legitimate exclusion or whatever
it's called
there you go and so keep them for a low
retention now there are a couple of
tools that are trying to do this and
there are some open source tools trying
to do tracing which is slightly slightly
different and so you've got things like
Yeager and Zipkin that are doing the
tracing type things the two I'm going to
focus on which is the tool I like I know
I am wearing their t-shirt I'm not an
employee of honeycomb just saying I just
think they're awesome and I think what
they're doing is pretty different to
everything else that's out there so
they're based around production
debugging they they use case these high
usage systems so if you've got something
that's getting four or five requests
just to log in I mean so don't worry
just just lock some stuff out and keep
it for as long as you want if you're
doing something that is incredibly high
load you need something that he's built
for that use case and at the scale that
some people are that there's not that
many people that are out there but this
is an example of what they're doing
so you've got millions millions of
pieces a day are going through that
platform you're then how do you sift
through that data is it just a graph
showing averages it's not really going
to give you that you want to be able to
drill in you want to be able to see
correlations that kind of stuff so they
are more than just graphs and things
like Zipkin things like jäger then more
than just graphs they're built around
you being able to debug that production
system now the other thing is I built
the honeycomb net library so slightly
biased but it's very very easy to use
and I built it based on the ideas of the
other two things that we've looked at
the log in and the metrics where bring
it in add some data to it and what
you're doing here is an event is created
for every single request now you've got
one context which is your request and
the idea of these tools is just add more
data to that request don't worry about
it having four or five hundred fields on
there just add everything sample it if
you need to
if you're doing way way too much data
sample it but just add everything into
it and again
couple things in your config file to do
it so I'll go through a bit and I'm
going to do the same as we've done with
the others
and bring that in
okay one of the key things of the way
that I built this and the reason why I
didn't come up this with a pre-built
solution is to show you about layering
some of these things on there because
we've got what something like twelve
references in there now it's much easy
for you to see when we've actually added
just little bits on as we've gone so
we've got honeycomb in there now and
we've got some settings that we put in
and we'll call its NDC
okay
that key will be gone by the end of this
presentation just sayin so don't try it
cool so we've got them in there and
throw in our
I'll say about file
so that's and sell it to use any gum
okay that is as easy as adding on
economies in there run that through now
what you'll find is this is a little bit
less impressive than the other ones when
you're talking about small data sets
because the graphs don't look half as
pretty however what I will do is they
have a play sign for you to look at of
what your data will look like when you
add it to a production system and see
lots and lots of data in there
so it doesn't look half as impressive as
anything that you've seen on there but
the raw date is there in there and as
you can see it's just added individual
items line items in there that's every
single request that's gone through the
system that's the default position for
these libraries if you just log
everything you need some plate if you
want to but keep it for a very short
period of time and log everything now
if you go through their place out and
this is where this tool comes into its
own I don't looking at that one I can do
a look at this so if we start to think
about a heat map which is in my opinion
the best tool that you've got when
you're looking at high load systems
so you start to see that and this is
where the really cool part comes in so
you've got a graph you've got some data
in there
imagine that is millions and millions of
requests a second that you've got going
through there you think about metrics
you've lost fidelity so you can't really
drill in and find any more information
on that if you think about logs I really
want to be searching through that many
logs are not like you book and that is
not really the most pleasant experience
but with things like this what you can
actually do is you can zoom into that
and have it blow out every single one of
those metrics graph every single one of
them and see you've human pin point some
of that information so when you're
starting to look at really really high
load systems you need to be leveling up
that monitoring logs and metrics they
just aren't good enough they have use
cases that you have to really think
about that's why when people say oh yeah
we're doing login or we're doing metrics
well great are you doing logging and
metrics are you just doing logs and then
you're building some metrics off the
back of it what are you using them for
think about them as individual elements
that you've really got to think about
what their actual use case is so my
timing is well off and I mow it through
quite a lot there and so I put up some
resources on there they are all
available out there for you to and to
have a play with and considering we have
twenty minutes early finishing I will
more than happily take a battering with
questions but if not thank you very much
for coming
anybody Oh
hair question what's the price price
options for honeycomb and I think it's
about how much you want to store it's
all based on how much how long do you
want to store that data so I think
cheapest is something like 70 dollars
and bought it can go up to quite a lot
it depends on how much data you put it
in and how much you want to store how
much you want to sample so if you only
want 10% of your data if that's a
representative set then you can just
take 10% and obviously reduce that to
attention around so to you about working
out how much how much is valuable to you
in terms of how far back you want to go
but it's to encourage you to only think
about things about debugging in
production because you don't debug
something that happened three weeks ago
three weeks ago something's gone wrong
you're right I'm on the computer right
now doing it the alerts have gone off my
monitoring is the that's based on
metrics has all gone off right great
let's go on there and look at honeycomb
well let's go on there and look at Jager
or zip kin or any of those tools there
are point in time things it's not about
going back three years and working out
what happened or a trend of say well
what happened last year versus this year
what happened last month versus this
month
it's about look there are some key
things here whether it's response times
of a third party or whether it's the the
average response time of a particular
page but I want to know why that
happened and I want to know what the
differentiator is between the requests
that were long and the requests that
were sure was it someone one of the
third parties that was running slow
which caused the home page to go slow
which we have had on our company where
somebody's put something in there on
every single home page cold calls a
third party and that third party ends up
being slow which means you home pages
mean slow but it's only for partly
requests so you need to know what those
differentiates are but it happens in the
moment I say four days is a really good
time period because you've got the
weekend and you've got a weekend covered
then so yes
yeah well they're worth yeah I mean you
do flick the switch on the when you've
gone vacation but that's more you flip
the internal switch because you don't
care anymore and it's somebody else's
problem Oh at the back
totally separate things as far as I'm
concerned and the the the stuff where
you will actually enrich your logs with
something like a trace identifier or the
request identifier in dotnet core which
is a really cool thing that's added by
the framework those ones are really
interesting especially if you throw them
through and the default era page is
where you can actually pull out the
request identifier and then you can
search through the logs if you're using
something centralized logs like the
elasticsearch example then you can
search for that request identifier and
then see all the logs that we related to
it I'm seeing less and less use cases
for that now when you get to high volume
systems because it's more for me now
around tracing which is the the sort of
next evolution for me so that's the idea
that you've got one request and I'm not
talking about distributing because
people every time you mentioned tracing
think I've got five services across
three different systems and I need to
correlate a request that goes through
this system this system this system that
to me is not what tracing is that's
distribution yep but tracing to me you
can even trace it through your own
application and you have a common trace
identifier that will use a request
identifier or trace identifier in dotnet
and you can trace that through you can
add individual items to each one of
those spans as they're going through you
can see the waterfall chart has been
quite a few talks over the last couple
of days on using tracing tools like zip
kin like Jaeger and honeycomb do one as
well that do the waterfall graphs that
you can then see where the bottlenecks
were on an individual request which is
immensely useful something we use a lot
of the time and because it's individual
maybe it's a date based lock on a
particular function that's happening so
that I don't know whether that answers
your question but it is to me that's
more around tracing than it is
specifically around logging
yeah so metrics are really useful for
things like alerting a monetary so your
big dashboard that you have the is
behind all of your developers so that
when the management company say pretty
graphs anything and that is what you use
for alerting that's what you use to fire
off your Victor up so your pager duty or
your ops genie that's those are what
metrics to me are about because if
something's going wrong that thing is
going to be read you know that if you've
got your your your threshold set right
something's going wrong at least one to
three of those is going to be going off
now that isn't going to pinpoint the
problem most of the time but that's your
indicator that there is a problem and
it's then right let's go to town let's
work out how we're actually going to do
something with it now so that's where
things like honey calm that that's
things work Jaeger when you jump into
whether it's a your centralized logging
solution that's when you jump into
bringing all those together and for me
that is we're tracing comes in not
specifically where logs personally as
you can probably tell I don't use logs
that much anymore
I'm sorry another question
so if you're doing things like
elasticsearch and you're logging out to
elastic shirts you can do your own
elastic search cluster and you would be
logging into another system inside of
your own infrastructure
there's loads of ones that elastic
search isn't the only one look down the
sinks that are on serie log there are
how many about a 70 or 80 so there are
loads of places where you can log these
things that's just one example because
it allows really good searching I
believe there's a tool called SEC out
there that does something like this and
butts and but yeah there is a lots of
solutions where you put it inside of
your own system but it's all about using
purpose-built systems now is a database
the right solution and it's your
database where your actual transactions
are going through the right place to
fire all these logs through and then
somebody goes oh I'm going to do a
full-text search that's going to search
every bit of data 800 why can nobody my
can't nobody pay for anything oh yeah
because I was just trying to search logs
sorry and so using a second system is
always what I would recommend whether
that's a third party system that you
host elsewhere scaling elastic search to
multiple nodes that kind of stuff that's
a skill in itself and so I wouldn't
recommend that I would for us we use AWS
we use the end of us elastic search
service because it is just fire it up
and then point things at it it is just
off the shelf to do it and it works out
off the shelf with is your ones any
elastic search cluster that there is
elastic search is just the easiest one
to get up and running especially in a
docker container I'll hip hop but it is
purpose-built for things like searching
those logs and doing correlations and
you can pull metrics off the top of it I
do play that down quite a lot but you
can pull some metrics off the top of an
elastic search logging cluster and use
that for graphs and that kind of stuff
for questions
yeah and I knew that would come up and I
I have a little bit looked at it it
looks really cool it's quite new and
haven't done much with it in all honesty
if anybody has some really good
information out I will be around for the
last couple of days come and talk to me
about because I really want to hear what
he's what he's good at
if you yeah I mean all of that is
information that you would put in there
honeycomb is just the tool to provide
your querying capabilities if you were
to add in the country code as context to
that particular request absolutely that
would then break that out as you saw on
that graph where you can just zoom in
that would break out your country codes
and say well it used to be this fast for
that country code and now it's not so it
won't off the shelf do that now it is
something that you've got to add in all
of that contacts yourself know you can
add triggers
yeah that's that's why I always I
believe this is more akin to a debugging
tool than it is anything else because
when you are debugging something you're
not going through and saying and I can
you tell me what was wrong
you're stepping through you're looking
at what the parameters were you're
looking at well what's how is this
different is this going through that
method rather than this method you're
not you're not having your visual studio
debugger go well it's your country code
see the country codes wrong or this
country codes slower is you debugging
through that code this is just a way of
putting all of that data in an easily
queryable format very very high loads I
can't stress that enough for me and I'm
sure they will say different Honeycomb
but for me it's only comes into its own
when you're talking about high high load
systems because that is where you start
thinking about only testing and
production anymore cool well thank you
very much and thanks for the questions
as well
[Applause]